a british rapper named zooby
okay garnered worldwide attention to
march 2019 after post
uh posting a video of himself declaring
he had broken the british women deadlift
record
in the tweet zooby said that he
identified as a woman whist
lifting the weight ultimately trolling
the debate of transgender people
competing
in athletic events he claimed to have
broken a woman deadlift record of 238
kilograms that's 528 pounds
and he said it was without even trying
different athletic organizations both in
the united states and around the world
have
their own policies in place to include
the
transgender athletes the international
olympic committee a national collegiate
athletic association and the naia
all have rules that say transgender
women need to pass certain tests u.s
powerlifting however does not allow
transgender women to compete as women so
can we play this video if you don't mind
just play the video of him doing it
because i think everybody needs to see
this this is you
look at that though damn that's a clean
lift i could have done like five of
those
four million views your tweet i keep
hearing about how biological men don't
have any physical strength advantage
over women in 2019
so watch me destroy the british woman
deadlift record without even trying p.s
i didn't identify it as a woman
was lifting the weight don't be a bigot
the the inside grip by the way sumo
deadlift
solid yeah man if gerard approves you
know it's legit so this guy benches what
gave you the idea of wanting to do this
because everybody was talking about this
so we'll give you the idea
no doubt so since like when would have
been when did the world start going
super silly like 2015 2016 i was
following these stories
and seeing this happening right this is
when new gender started being introduced
to the western world
and people could identify as anything
and i was like well this is ultimately
going to lead to
you know there's going to be downstream
repercussions of this i can see what's
happening
i saw what happened with uh fallon fox
in mma
and then in some collegiate areas i
think both in
the in canada and the usa i was just
seeing you know male athletes
competing against girls and women by
identifying
as the opposite gender and i said okay
you know what
if that if those are the rules let's
take this to its logical conclusion so
out of curiosity i just did a quick
google search of okay in my weight class
what's the british women's deadlift
record and
i saw it was 215 kilos i know my pb's
275.
so i was like oh okay and then i just
had that video on my phone from one of
my training sessions
of me doing pulling 230. oh so you
didn't do this afterwards
that was just from one of my training
sessions and i so i just took it i just
tweeted
at the time i had 18 000 twitter
followers i thought this is going to get
a couple retweets a couple lols
and i did not know this was going to be
the thing that would introduce me to
millions of people
all around the world i put that tweet
out there and within seconds
i knew something was up i was just
looking at my phone like
okay within 10 minutes the video had 10
000 views
and it just kept growing and growing it
was getting retweeted
all over the world by huge personalities
people were commenting in different
languages and for days and days and days
this thing was just going viral going
viral going viral
after a while joe rogan picks up on it
talks about it on his podcast which
gives it this whole second absolutely
boost and
i mean that that was march 2019 and some
and it's gone viral several times since
then because people will pick up again
on the story
plus two equals five for two years two
plus two equals freaking five man
and then of course in the olympics now
you've had uh um
this thing came came to head again right
where new zealand had their first
uh transgender weightlifter who failed
anyway
but that caused a big stir so the story
sort of is one of those things that just
keeps coming back
what do you what do you think they
should do i mean right now it's the
olympics right i mean what do you think
they should do so by the way there are
some people that
you know they strongly believe they want
to be transgender sure okay so
let it be it's a libertarian mindset do
as you choose but how do you think the
olympics
should handle transgenders simple i
think
you there there's there's two options
either they kind of lead to the same
result
firstly most people don't understand
that most male sports
are not actually male sports they're
just open right but it's anyone can
complete yeah but it turns out there's
never been
for obvious reasons there's never been a
very important to repeat what you just
said so in olympics most male sports are
open
yeah i i'm not sure about olympic
specific sports in general
you know i don't believe the nba the nfl
the mlb they don't have a rule saying
women are like you see these women
become like nfl kickers or even college
in youth sports in america
you know especially because women
develop faster than young boys do young
girls so like up until
as late as 12 13 years old girls soccer
plays girls and boys basketball girls
and boys it's open small girls
it just turns out that you know there's
never been a woman big and strong enough
to play in the nfl
or in the nba etc which is why you have
a women's sports division so it's the
women's sports divisions that are
that are exclusive whereas the others
open so you just have an open category
so however you identify whatever best of
the best
and then you have a female category
simple
that's all yeah the the the interesting
thing is like look
it you're talking about a meritocracy at
the end of the day right like if
somebody's good enough like i always
thought that the the person who really
could break down a gender barrier in a
sports
is a knuckleballer like a knuckleball
pitcher if there's a woman who could
throw a knuckleball you throw it 65
miles an hour it's about the movement of
the ball
the softer you throw it the more
effective it is you don't need to
overpower
that's somebody that could actually
break down a gender barrier she doesn't
need to she doesn't need to run as fast
as anybody else she doesn't need to
swing the bat
she can literally use a technique a
technical
uh pitch and be able to compete at that
level so that that would be something
but like what vanderbilt did by running
that kicker out so she could kick the
ball 30 yards out of bounds
oh yeah break the gender barriers of the
sec and it was like my god
you turned this poor girl into a show
pony that's what you did you took this
poor girl and you told her you turned
her into a
show pony for your progressive ideology
she won she won
sec special teams player of the week for
a
30-yard kickoff out of bounds what's the
one thing you always joke about like
i got one year of eligibility of college
left baseball i brought it up i might go
okay guys as soon as joe biden like one
of his very first uh
one of his very first executive orders
from from our uh
our king was to say no questions asked
to to uh basically reverse what they
would call the the transgender
discrimination that trump had done
and say that no questions asked anybody
who identifies as a woman
will should be able to compete in
athletics ncaa athletics
uh as as their their gender identity so
i'm like okay
i could as a former professional
baseball player go back
at my age and play softball
at the university of miami with a metal
freaking bat
you're going to let me hit a ball
against 17 year old girls
who and and if i if if i hit a ball up
the middle and i murder a pitcher
or the third baseman is just getting
kneecapped that's okay
that's equality because god forbid you
tell me no bro
you're a 34 year old man go anywhere but
here
that's that's the part that's bigotry
not me
showering with a 17 year old 18 year old
girl
in the locker room with a 17 18 year old
girl uh
you know dorming with them practicing
with them and competing against them
that's equality but if you if you
preclude me from that
well you're a bigot you know for me the
way i see it is the following why don't
you just create a
a transgender competition let them go at
it let them compete
let them go at it rather than having to
go and take things away from women if
you
if you want to create a transgender you
know
contest competition go for it i don't
think i don't see anything wrong with
that
where you're competing against somebody
their their argument pat
is that they're not transgender yeah
you're dealing with ideologues did you
did you
hear did you hear the uh argument
navertolovo made
no have you have you heard the argument
she made i heard
i'm not sure can you pull it up can you
pull up her argument she made the uh
tennis player navratilova man that to
spell that name kai
tina i think you out of any
everybody should be able to spell that
nice spelling
okay transgender she said something
about that she said some
quote about it uh who's a girl in
tennessee she said now zones are
critical
so when she rejects that transformation
click on news
there's a story about this yeah i saw
that um
okay uh go back guy go back there was a
story right at the top
right there click on that i think that's
2019 well that's when it was when she
said it though go go up
uh she said something very powerful
uh and by the way navertolova is fully
supportive of gay rights well she is gay
yeah i know she is but she said
something here
are you know something anyways you guys
can continue i'll find this quote here
to read it to you it's a powerful
statement she made
i just have one question because quite
candidly
this is not anything that i'm like
waking up being like what are the trans
saying today this is not
like what percentage of the world are
transgender like
point zero zero one percent like a
fraction of a fraction of a factor okay
so why is this such a big deal because
they're infusing themselves into the pop
culture and sports
it's because it's been it's being forced
on people yeah absolutely right
because most people look regardless of
whether someone it shouldn't even be
political but whether someone is
liberal conservative libertarian
whatever most people don't care if
you're an adult
do what you want to do maybe i don't get
it maybe i don't you know agree with it
whatever
but if that's what you want to do it's
not harming anyone live your life how
you want you're a man you want to wear a
dress you want to put up makeup
you know you're allowed to you can do
you can do what you want the problem
with this
issue is that they're you know and again
most most transgender people i've
probably no more most people don't know
any i actually know a couple
i don't know any who's in favor of this
whole sports thing right they think it's
crazy because they recognize reality so
it's just the woke left trying to use
their ideas
idea laws exactly trans are like yo
we're good yeah we don't miss your help
but this is something that would
potentially
chelsea handlers yeah but there's
something that impacts 50 of the
population
right why is it the men aren't worried
about this yeah because it's right it's
not going to affect them exactly which
ex which in itself
blows up the entire argument absolutely
brought up fallon fox and she's
literally caving
she was caving women's faces who is she
she was a transgender mma fighter yeah
she was a man
this is the problem was a man no became
a woman and was able to compete against
other women yeah and
cave now is it more common for women to
become men
can i can i jump in here and say that
you cannot actually change your
biological sex it's not possible
okay so even saying she you're giving in
to the argument
you're not talking about a she you're
talking about a biological male you
cannot change from a man
into a woman it's not possible you can
make yourself appear as such you can
identify as such
but it is not physically possible and i
think part of it is this overt political
correctness with people having to
you know respect the pronouns and change
their whole language
to defy reality which actually allows
people to run with these crazy arguments
because as soon as you start calling
someone a woman they're like well if
they're a woman why can't they compete
against women and i'm like no that's not
a woman that's a biological male
identifying
as a woman why because when you're young
you go through puberty and if you're
born a boy you go through you got the
hormones
no well rogan's
you know muscle retention i mean we're
we we are he's right
we're so bilateral there is nothing that
any of us here at this table
can do that would turn us into damn
that's bad news i thought i could
who's the most famous transgender person
in the world caitlyn jenner probably
okay so i have one quick story about
this so
um i my one of my best friends is that
guy chris humphries that married kim
kardashian i was
in the wedding i walked chloe down the
aisle bruce was there this was
he know he's been doing 2 000 what's
that you're just dead named someone's
going to cancel you oh all right well it
happens well it's called dead naming oh
because
he doesn't exist anymore but at the time
it was bruce jenner that was like tying
our tie
point is this what's your language you
know
buddy yeah it's a minefield yeah i gotta
go yeah
it was probably 2017. talk about a
future governor she did
i don't think that's happened she came
out on diane sawyer on believe like 2020
and did the whole
thing or whatever but here's the story
that night um
chris was playing for the wizards at the
time washington wizards and they had
just swept
the toronto raptors right drake was at
the game was a big deal
it was breaking news caitlyn jenner
announces because there was rumors that
was going on right and it was
you know after the game we're
celebrating sweep we're having dinner
having drinks
and this is and i was like this is some
weird [ __ ] huh and he's like
yeah like thank god i got out while i
did and i go you gotta tweet that
and he goes no hell no i go i literally
i'm like give me your phone i've never
tweeted before in my life
and i tweeted on chris's
this was me i'm owning up to it you
canceled him like thank god i got out
well i just ended his career
not so much because of the jenner thing
but because look at the track record
that happened that cardet
lamar odom you know od scott disick
rehab
the father like literally died robert
kardashian hasn't been
the son hasn't been seen in years i'm
like look at you bro you're worth
50 million you just swept the you know
the uh
the raptors your life's great and he
goes dude i got no ill will towards
caitlyn yeah but like thank god i gotta
kind of got out what i did so i took his
phone
and i tweeted it i'm like haha like we
did it like huh and like
dude an hour later his publicist calls
what's up
he's getting slaughtered slaughtered on
twitter
he didn't throw you under the bus though
he came out made an apology he wasn't
gonna be like my boy saw his like i
could have been my phone was hacked
yeah it literally was but he came out
made an apology
and like the next i was staying with him
he goes never [ __ ] touch my phone
again
oh man but he got slaughtered
in the many months that we've been with
uh adam sauce i have not seen chris
humphries not one
freaking he ain't coming yeah yeah he'll
be out there he'll be
here he's gonna come yeah
anyway it's a very sensitive topic but
it's at least we're talking about it so
respect to what you're doing at least
making it
something dude caitlyn jenner's got one
of the greatest quotes of all time too
afterwards she said in l.a it was easier
to come out as transgender than it was
to come out as a republican
oh yeah oh wow that's believable you get
you get embraced and celebrated by
you know the hyper wokies for the former
and you get denigrated for the latter so
it's not surprising especially in
california gosh
yeah that's actually shocking that you
said that because that's pretty
ridiculous
that's what it's her truth so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye